and we have a warning tonight here at  five from the drug enforcement  administration  scammers are impersonating dea agents in  an attempt to steal your identity and  steal your money  you can also check me online do you want  me to send you my badge picture right  now  party got your best number and  everything yeah you have my bachelor but  you don't have my batch picture yet my  friend  otherwise you will not ask me this kind  of question  tricky right so just a reminder the dea  will never call or ask for any personal  information over the phone  and any legitimate investigations are  going to be notified by an official  letter